[Applaudissements]
je n'ai pas d'avis bienvenue on n'a
qu'une seule fille on s'amuse les
profanes que les filles sont fatiguées
je suis amoureux
moi tant peiné
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
si je te réponds pas j'entends pas ce
que tu dis si c'est négatif le tournage
apprécié mes gars qui fait quoi
s'interroger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et vous
je suis dans mon délire grenade mais on
se démerde pour mener une vie qui
courrait nu clair tout petit j'essaye de
me faire chier dans mes affaires oui je
crie p67 l'échelle rejetant maire serge
mourinho en train de concocter dans le
thiec je vais pas quitter les cochons
s'est pas quitté ailleurs que son indice
le reste allez je gère ce mois l'artiste
est venu
une
je suis
sont tués
[Musique]
ce qu'un sujet
m
ce
oh
[Musique]
coc
je
bon
si je te répond pas ne manquent pas
[Applaudissements]
si je ne réponds pas mais nombreux bas
aussi
apa